rwandan troops have made progress
pushing back armed groups in northern
mozambique since being deployed there
two months ago their rapid success has
raised concerns about the effectiveness
of mozambique's own security forces
rwanda sent about a thousand soldiers
into the resource-rich cabo delgado
province back in july
and alongside local forces they're
helping people travel safely to and from
the town of palmer that's suffered some
of the worst violence
let's take a closer look at the growing
security threat in the region
conflict there has escalated in northern
mozambique since an insurgency back in
2017. the government says isil-linked
fighters are operating in parts of kabul
delgado province destroying villages and
kidnapping people
an armed group known locally as
al-shabaab in mozambique is behind much
of the conflict their fighters have been
intensifying raids across villages in
cabo delgado over the past four years
but the government security forces have
also been accused of grave human rights
violations amnesty international says
there is evidence of them torturing
prisoners
and dismembering opposition fighters
the violence has killed more than three
thousand people so far and displaced
over six hundred and seventy thousand
let's bring in borges namire he is a
research consultant at the institute for
security studies he joins us via skype
from
maputo many thanks for joining the
program
it does sound like the random army has
achieved more in just a few days then
the mozambique army managed an entire
year why do you think that is
well that's true
rwandan have done in just two months
what mozambique and could not do in
almost four years and that's simple to
asset it's because iranians are better
prepared to face the insurgents they
have
better
equipment wheel points they have a
better intelligence and they have bet
the men better prepared compare it to
mozambique and that's simple to ask
why is the rwandan government getting
involved i mean they say it's for
humanitarian reasons but is there a an
ulterior
motive well uh
that's much complex to explain uh
rwandan they say they are here because
of international solidarity uh to assist
most american people that's very uh
beautiful to hear
but we all understand that there might
be a you know like a
and on interest to rwanda so how we can
understand it we'll understand first
that rwandan are not in all the province
of of capital god but they are all
present in two districts palmer and the
muslim were the prior and the doors are
the most important district in terms of
lng project while the two billion at the
the 20 billion
usd lng project is in the palmer a
museum of the prayer is important for
logistics so everything that we see now
it's like rwandan are there to protect
to create and protect a security
perimeter of lng facility to allow
the french company total to come back to
palmer and operate
okay so uh the rwandan army have been
successful in pushing back some of this
islamic threat
terrorist threat so what happens now do
the rwandans continue to
have a base there to continue keeping
the threat out
yes ronan keep
the operations in mozambique but also
shall not ignore the presence of the
sudden force i mean we who are engaged
in
several districts compared to the
rwandans london are now operating in
only two districts while the sadek force
are present in almost five districts so
the joint of international force which
will make up uh around seven african
countries are all of them operating in
that region alongside with mozambican
force
how do the locals feel about the rwandan
presence there
well ordinary citizens they feel
comfortable ordinary citizens they feel
happy that they can see
some strong men and women on the ground
protecting them and their properties we
cannot deny that
but when we it comes to the political
level opposition uh press and some
academic people they are concerned about
the agreement which brought the rwandans
to mozambique because that is not public
so people are questioning for how long
are they going to stay what is their
role what they can do what are their
powers so it will say that there is a
mixed view ordinary citizens are happy
they just need someone who can protect
them but when it comes to their you know
elite and some academic people
politicians they are questioning what
are they doing here what is the
agreement the agreement which brought
one and to muslim because not public
noun it didn't go through the parliament
so there is a concern about what will
come in the future when the situation of
the security situation is solved then
what will be the bill that mozambique
going to have to pay back to rwanda
very interesting to get your thoughts uh
borges namire speaking to us there from
maputo